大家好 欢迎观看新的一集 FP101x
今天要学习的是在 Haskell 中定义函数
我觉得你们当中不在家乡上大学的人
或多或少都有这样的经历
你离开自己长大 上小学和中学的家乡 前往大学
十年后回到故乡
事物发生了些许的变化
但同时又似曾相识
但这可能让你有点晕头转向
因为记忆中的事物没有改变 而在现实中已经不同了
学 Haskell 时会有类似的感受
Haskell 和其他编程语言看起来很像 但又有细微的不同
本讲要介绍的是 Haskell 的函数定义与表达式书写的语法
并与其他编程语言中的实现方式相比较
当注意到区别时 它们就很容易使用了
但在 Haskell 中的确有一些不同之处
尤其是和 Java PHP 或者你喜欢的语言中的习惯相比
第一件要讲的是条件表达式
每门语言都有条件表达式 通常也会区分使用 if then else 写的条件语句
和用 ? 和 : 三元表达式写的条件表达式
其他语言也有用 if then else 写表达式的 比如 Scala
但在 C# 和 Java 中 条件语句和条件表达式的语法不同
Haskell 中没有语句 因此使用 if then else 表达条件
本例中定义一个函数 接受一个整数 返回另一个整数
这是取绝对值的函数
它接受一个值 当值大于等于 0 时 返回 n 否则返回 -n
对值取反 这里使用的是熟悉的 if then else 表达式形式
当然 因为它只是一个表达式 因此也可以嵌套
同样因为条件表达式是表达式 因此总是需要有 then 和 else 部分
这个例子定义了符号数 signum
n 小于 0 时是 -1 n 等于 0 时是 0 n 大于 0 时是 1
如同三元表达式一样 then 和 else 分支是必要的
因为 Haskell 程序员喜欢简洁 通常不用条件表达式 而是用所谓的守卫（guarded）等式
守卫等式捕获了一种常见的模式 即以条件开始的函数
如果函数定义的等式右边立刻接着一个条件 最好使用守卫等式
因此在左侧写函数的定义 接下来写条件
因此 n 的绝对值是
当 n 大于等于 0 时为 n
否则是 -n 其中的 否则 相当于 True
回到这里的定义 使用条件表达式计算绝对值
可以看到函数定义中立刻接了一个条件表达式
Haskell 程序员更喜欢这样写 可以看到右侧更简单 条件也更清楚了
可以很轻松地进行思考
当 n 大于等于 0 时 当 n 小于 0 时 对于其他的函数
尤其是嵌套的条件时 就更值得这样做了
为了定义符号数 signum 如果小于 0 是 -1 如果等于 0 则是 0 否则是 1
从中可以看到 Haskell 中的数学传统 写法很简洁
守卫等式是地道的 Haskell 写法
因此通常不写 if then else 而是写守卫等式
另一件 Haskell 中大量使用 而其他现代语言较少使用的就是模式匹配（pattern matching）
比如 Scala 中有模式匹配 但需要使用 case 语句才能做到
C# 使用选择（switch）语句
但在 Haskell 中 定义函数时可以直接使用模式匹配
比如定义逻辑取反 是一个从布尔值到布尔值的函数 可以直接模式匹配
not False 等于 True not True 等于 False
这样定义的逻辑取反十分简洁
再比如定义逻辑与 && 类型是从布尔到布尔再到布尔
可以直接写下 && 的真值表
如果查 && 在数字逻辑中的定义的话 就会找到相同的真值表
我们可以写下来 但仔细看看 其实可以写得更简洁
因为只有当两个参数都为真时 结果才为真
其他情况下都是假
因此将四种情况缩减为两种
True && True 等于 True 否则无论什么 && 什么都为 False
下划线在 Haskell 中很普遍 意思是无关的变量 仅仅作为模式匹配中的占位符
观察这个定义可以看出 为了进行匹配会对两个参数均进行求值 因为在 && 的两侧都有模式
Haskell 程序员对此很敏感 因为 Haskell 是一门惰性（lazy）语言 希望求值越少越好
为了得到函数调用的答案 一个更好的定义
在地道的 Haskell 中是这样的 如果是 True 那么 True && b 的结果为 b 如果是 False 那就是 False
让我们验证一下 Ture && True 是 True True && False 是 False 因此结果与后面的值相同
如果左侧是 False 那么右侧无论是什么都无所谓
结果总是 False
这是 && 的最优定义 因为它仅对第一个参数进行必要的求值
Haskell 中的模式是按顺序匹配的 准确来讲是 从左到右 从上到下
编译器不会对模式进行重排来优化 因为顺序很重要
也可以把模式匹配和守卫等式混合使用
可以简单记住 模式是从左到右 从上到下进行匹配的
变量不能重复
比如不能写 b && b 等于 b 假设其中的 b 是相等的
模式中的变量都应该是唯一的
我们讲过用方括号表示列表 这实际上只是使用 cons 和空表的语法糖
当一个列表出现在某处时 意思是下面这样的 但在模式匹配中
常常需要将列表写成下面的形式 比如定义列表的头元素 head 可以用如下的模式匹配
我们将列表写为 头（head） cons 尾（tail）形式
一个列表分成头元素 x 和一个不关心的尾 其头元素就是 x
一个列表分成一个我不关心的头元素和一个尾 xs 其尾就是 xs
这是一个很简洁的定义
让我们看看类型 tail 接收一个列表 由于列表的尾仍然是一个列表 因此类型是 列表到列表
head 接收列表 但其头元素的值是列表的元素类型 因此其类型是 [a] 到 a
当然 它们不是全函数（total function）因为没有在空表上定义 当将 head 应用到空表上时 没有模式匹配上
因此会出错 tail 也一样
另一种说法是 x:xs 这样的模式只匹配非空列表 如果用空列表调用 head 不会匹配 因为它不是 x cons 什么的形式
当 head 应用到空表上时 没有模式匹配 因此会出错
另一件事是要在列表模式上加括号 因为函数应用具有最强的结合性
因此这里的意思变成了 x 的头元素再 cons 上任何东西 只有加上括号才能正常工作
这是在 Haskell 中定义函数的第一部分
休息之后再见